Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and
welcome back to "Oxygen Not Included".
We're still...
um...
We're still on the same boat where we were,
but I'm trying my best today...
to just get their stress down, because these guys...
Oh, these poor guys and poor Lenny...
Oh, Jeez... and he's died right where everyone has to go take a shit!
Oh... That's just... This is not good.
So, what we're gonna do...
is eventually, we're gonna dig the slime,
we got more algae...
they're gonna build a tasteful memorial...
I'll try to prioritize that, I guess.
And then, hopefully there's going to be
some options for these guys to...
do this.
It's... it's so bad though, because
the second...
that I repair anything,
they destroy it.
The s... the very second I repair something...
they destroy it, which is making it nearly impossible.
Oh, Stacy's sad.
Oh my God, they're instantly all painting.
Geez.
Oh, wow, that's... Damn!
*chuckles*
(reading) "Crude painting." That's ok, though.
You did what you could.
It's not helping a lot, but you did what you could.
These are broken, too. It's all broken.
*sighs* Oh, man.
(reading) "Food beyond reach?"
Also, just not enough oxygen across the board.
Ok, so we gotta focus now.
We gotta focus, 'cause if don't, we're gonna die.
So we gotta get this slime.
'Cause it's something,
it's something.
It.. it is something.
So, the bio distiller's going to make the slime...
we gotta prioritize building this wall...
so that we don't die.
Goddamnit, they keep cutting the power
every
single
time.
I've decided I'm gonna try to connect these two power sources...
because then at least I can repair this one...
and hopefully repair that battery and ignore the algae deoxidizer for now.
Well, I probably need one. It'd be nice just to have one,
wouldn't it?
Ok, so that's gonna be sealed off...
those are gonna be dug out...
whenever they get to that,
they've got other priorities at the moment, but...
that's going to be dug...
How did you get stranded there?
Josie, damn it!
*whispering* Jesus. God damn.
Okay. Fine, then.
Alright. So, you got the slime...
Slime's in there, slime's in there.
That's gonna produce contaminated oxygen, I know...
but it's also gonna run off...
contaminated water.
We're getting slime...
Slime's gonna turn into algae,
we'll be able to algae these up...
We'll be able to...
have this deoxidizer going....
Hopefully, anyway.
Ok, alright.
*sighs*
So someone's carving up there, that's good, I guess.
These are broken.
These have no power.
The mush bars aren't running.
They're breaking the batteries, of course.
This is broken.
That's being repaired, that's being repaired.
That's been dug out good.
We've got algae going.
*Aye yai yai*
Ok, but at least it's something,
so now that this is going on...
we're getting algae,
which at the very least is something that is...
like, something that we desperately need.
And I know, I know it is.
I very much notice, and obviously this is...
filling up with contaminated oxygen, I know.
I know that.
It's bad.
We'll do what we can.
That's why we got an airlock, like, getting both of them.
That generator is going.
The algae is going.
We're getting the algae.
Gotta get more.
Fixing what we can...
'cause everyone keeps breaking it, but that's okay.
I can't blame it and I'm just trying to fight stress.
So what we need is... we need...
We need some sort of medicine...
'cause these guys' health are (is) probably very low.
No, their health is ok.
*sighs*
The decor is down, of course the decor is down.
What I also need to do is, I need to make storage stuff.
Storage compactors.
Just tons of 'em.
Just so we can clean this shit up. Have some place to put stuff.
New person, alright, bring 'em in!
Yeish.
Alright.
Wait, a Level 8 chef...
with gastrophobia that can't cook.
Great, that's exactly what we needed in this environment!
That's exactly what's gonna help us!
That is everything that we need!
*sighs* "Flatulence".
Alright, cool. Doris the Farter.
I'll take Doris the Farter.
At least someone's getting here with less stress.
Aw great, of course as soon as
the algae deoxidizer is up and running you
have to beat it up, Dan.
Dan, why?
Why Dan?
Just why?
Alright, so at least they're making food.
At least food is getting made.
If not there then lets...
try to keep it going up here.
Repair, repair, repair...
repair, repair...
repair, repair... just repair.
Whoa. Abstract structure crude mediocre
structure quaint
mm ok then see breaking, okay you can
break the batteries just don't break
the essential things.
Alright so we've got to get that
that thing some algae but for some reason
these aren't pumping is because they
don't have enough slime do they need
more slime?
'Cause I can do that, like that's
easy enough.
Oh, i just realized i can make a priority
nine-dig.
Whoa, hey.
So we eventually need is to
kind of just build upwards, I guess... but...
Oh fuck, the water supply. God dammit, the water!
*Hai yai yai*
Okay so we need to build a ladder down...
to here...
and dig this out...
Eventually. *Hang in there Mark!*
Oh, god dammit.
Oh, f*ck me...
Jesus!
Oh, god dammit... I have a leak
I have a leak this whole time!
Oh no.
Oh no, oh no.
contaminated ox...
oh, contaminated oxygen
was getting in the whole time
Shitty dicks!
Okay well just going to have some
scrubbers at the ready
Oh God...
Alright, well, priority up.
Alright, the... I know I could start over and...
it would be easier... But I am not giving up on my family! Everything seems bad and
everything is in crisis... But I will not give up on them!
I say as they vomit again...
But I won't give up I'm gonna see this through...
I'm going to save them. No matter what.
I'm gonna save them. Good now that's sealed off finally.
Can't believe I was just letting that leak in this whole time.
All my beautiful gas-permeable just went
to shit, didn't it? Anyway that's going to
filter that out hopefully in time
That'll deodorize it. Goddamnit, I wasn't paying
attention to the lashing out. Had to get
these repaired. See, it's so hard to make progress
now because I- there's so many people
that are just dedicating their time to
repairing like these haven't even been
able to be repaired just because
everyone's been focused over here so
there's been a big problem it would
probably do me a lot of good to connect
the wires from here
to here. 'Cause that way at least it will all be
in one big chunk and hopefully these can
power that and then not everything is
just on a constantly deadly system
hey at least they're breathing well
because they've got contaminated oxygen
so that's a thing. You know, I'm- I'm not going to
do this 'cause *whispering* there's not really a point.
Ok, so I'm gonna prioritize the cable connections here
God, I do not know why those- Why in the world...
The slime's not being got. I need to make
them i have to make that we don't all
right let's bring another one into the
fold all bodybuilder are that's probably
gonna help
yeah sure why not maja the body builder
okay so those are now connected to at
least the grid is connected and
everything is sharing power but that
means that we're going to need a lot
more power but hopefully I have a cold
generator
I do indeed of that so that way we can
have something constantly making power
and it's over here in the the shitty
area and that's connected to the power
grid and everything can have power at
least we don't have to worry about
people constantly running it for power
because when they run they consume more
oxygen and they've read more carbon
dioxide and they eat more food it's
always bad news bears so just everybody
gets the bed is anybody not have a bed
in the uncomfortable papers if anybody
not stressing the uncomfortable spaces
recovers and nori nori is really good
about managing stress
I can't even believe that the Norris
it's a champ nor the champ
she just deals with stress so well so
they're going to build a cold generator
and then we're always going to have coal
I may need to put a gas pump on that I
don't know it may pump-out contaminated
oxygen again I don't know but so long as
it's something we'll have something
there I've got into it with repairs
active and hopefully people don't have
to worry can finish it finish it finish
finish finish at come on Finnegan
Spanish double de somebody finish the
bailed and I should just I should just
get rid of that because that is what is
a burden for people to get a growth mon
almost there almost there come on
reliable all come on let's build a child
there's two people can stop falling down
every single time
alright come on just a little more just
a little more guys just stuff little
more
there we go okay it's done all right
capitalization is number nine so that's
going to get we have tons of coal i know
we have tons of coal
we've got we're very consumable or coal
we got tons of coal we got oodles of
coal so we're not hurting for coal here
and there's definitely more coal around.
So area that we can get that going and
no one breaks it looks fine. I don't know
why the bio still is not doing its thing
but it's not doing its thing
Panik stop breaking shit what if not
have called it
somebody get it call somebody get a
goddamn call anybody at any time can get
it some coal I've got too many things
priority 9 I need to baseline everything
to priority five just reset it just get a
solid reset on everything
God damnit they didn't get it coal. Why they do not get
coal? WHY did they not get coal?? I don't
know. Maybe they can tell me. Ooooh my god,
why is that not connected?
Why is that not connected?? Oh my god no.
Did I do that? Oh I did that didn't I?
okay I'm connecting some algae oxidizers
up here so hopefully we can take care of
this I mean this one air deodorizer is
taking care of some of the contaminated
oxygen and thankfully the contaminated
oxygen something that's readable I mean
they're all sick anyway so why not why
is no one getting a goddamn call it get
us some freakin cold are you kidding me
are you kidding me oh Jesus we're
running out of algae and we gotta get
more gotta just have to add more slime
got more slime blaze please for the love
of God get it cold man everyone is
freaking everything this someone please
get cold
why didn't suit so hard i what am i
doing now is I'm gonna try to get a
better food because I think that's
definitely going to help them but the
problem is that everyone is so
unbelievably like non-productive I don't
want to call them lazy but there is
non-productive Isco generator still have
not gotten cold even though it's that
priority night I have no idea why I'm
assuming it's just cuz every battery is
full and they're just doing fine without
it but I i have no idea so I'm going to
get these fill these with meal would
that way we'll have a good bit of food
there will have meal would to go they'll
be doing their thing and hopefully they
can focus on that instead of worrying
about eating mush cars
it's going to be a while before they're
able to be you know harvested but at
least they will be better off than they
just work think i heard one of them to
say what I'm sure they looking forward
to meal would boy
oh good they finished bats and now they
got access to that water good goddamn
time even if it's not done that annoys
me that that's not done because they're
breaking the connection anywhere know
what the heck is that although
overheated
whoa it's overheating how do you under
his something all I didn't even know
that we have to worry about cooling
really oh oh shit
hydro fan oh there's a lot of heat down
here
oh no does the Hydra fan run on water
use water
ah that's not good I didn't even realize
that heat dissipation with after beach
would be something that I would have to
worry about
I honestly had no idea how in the hell
do we do that i mean obviously he drives
so that's a bad place to put it at first
but maybe if we oh maybe if we give it a
way to go up it might just be a little
bit better if we can invent things up
words then i'm assuming that we can make
it just a little bit nicer fork so we're
going to have another layer of this
Keep building upwards guys, towards the sky.
The sky is the limit
ugh you damn right it is...
Okay, so as you can see it's starting to take shape in terms of the planning
ah
Not quite there in terms of everything else
but at least we got the plans underway
Ahhh we are probably going to want these to be...
there's probably gonna wanna be
a solid
station
I think anyway
At least that's my thought process just to keep things
contained just in case there's something
else up there that's grad ah the cold
generators fire away is it
oh good good good good there's 600 watts
I don't know how much bits produces much
better produce probably a good amount i
don't know how does compared to the
other one but we're completely out of
power so hopefully it does a little more
than nothing would be nice
we're still connected to anything get
broken that's a little way why is that
oh god no oh god no quiet that been ok
alright well that's their family that
didn't need to get built and apparently
were so big that things are starting to
lag down a little bit
remember this i even though i've been
playing this like for a long time
remember this game is in fact in earlier
it's in three alpha I've been able to
play up into this point in three alpha
that's amazing this game is just i love
this game i haven't been able to say and
just because I've been so panic that
everyone dying but I am having an
amazing time playing this game i love
every bit of this it is so fun like is
legitimately it is so fun just pure and
simple it's fun it's fun to watch these
guys struggle it was fun to watch you go
through it's fun to help these guys
survive in the only way I know how it is
terribly and it's just it's really
interesting to see how all these things
like come together and how they work and
how they may enter can
action how they intermingle and helpful
hopefully they'll survive all this shit
and if they don't oh my god that's bad
but you know it's just it's really cool
oh so that that emits carbon dioxide
that's dangerous
at least it's providing a lot of power
it's providing a lot of hours so we have
that everyone's doing their thing that's
good so it's bad tipper that does carbon
dioxide but at least it's over in the
contained area not in here which is
still not doing too good but it's doing
ok
who well apparently that's popping out
oxygen now so that's nice so we must be
getting something from the slime someone
must have scooped up some of this
because there's a lot of swine on the
ground here
sweet pending we got a lot of stuff
going on here so it's going to be a
world what Doris what what happened
Doris how did you get trapped in their
stores what the hell door is what the
hell happened to you
oh Jesus towards don't do that
you crazy taurus
or if I'm sorry I didn't mean for that
to happen to you
holy shit door oh alright then anyway so
they're continuing on their spree
we need to make some doors here but the
hear the fear that we're all doors and
they take destroy orders very seriously
they destroyed quick okay hopefully
that's going to allow the heat to drop
down from there and then vent upward so
that gets hotter up here even though for
some reason this is 28 and this is still
overheated the air around it isn't that
warm air
well we need a lot more algae and i
prioritize the sweep image and they
don't take sweet borders with priority
oh they did holy God they did
oh shit that did work you should still
be priority 90 person welcome to hell
thankee thankee I like pinky I want
thinking he doesn't seem like a very
good guy because got to negative traits
but I'm gonna take him anyway go on and
kinky you might be my new favorite
stinky a thinking how you doing you're
doing good by thinking they're sweeping
up there these are not pumping they're
awaiting delivery but that's okay
these are still stifled the leafy around
it is not too hot
I don't know where we got all this
contaminated oxygen in here from it
should be relatively closed off this
isn't even through all there's a hole
there i guess you could make that at
least everyone's so busy that they seem
to have forgotten their stress which
will eventually go down maybe somehow
why not I wait a minute well away well
with the pasta here at the club's get
out for the puff dough to puff to escape
i don't know i love the pumpkin escaped
or not
okay I'm gonna go a little bit longer on
this episode is because I want to make
sure that thing's actually get done away
what's happening with you okay good job
you for help man that pop this caper did
someone kill it
did someone lash out at the puffed and
kill it would be horrible
ok ok do I want to flood everybody and
just shunt contaminated water down there
got something that's an option
probably all this is out because it's
big hold and everything i'm doing
oh and business still here she's them I
didn't even realize that that was a hole
that's been there the entire time groups
fuckin who I would love someone to
compare these this base to someone who
actually knows how to play the game
because this is the cot damn nightmare
is obviously a horrible nightmare that
no one wants to be a part of and yet
here we are in the nightmare good as
good as good as now having a good time
mmm alright so everyone okay
was I good doing thank you pass out and
also starving again Elvis he cannot
sleep
always smelling auto stinky and bothered
by a puter dolder from auto all that's
so sad for you and I'm gonna make a bold
move here because I feel like I need to
make a bold move or else nothing is
going to happen so here's the deal
exactly what I built over here i'm gonna
build over there except this time it's
going to be unleashing a torrent of
water unlike anyone has ever seen
oh this is going to suck for a lot of
people and this might ruin absolutely
everything that i do but i need huh
something's gotta change here and I'm
just starting to get enough oxygen here
but then everyone keeps breaking the
oxygen things just as soon as they get
repaired so I need slime lots of it i
cleared out this which got me just
enough algae to be able to rejuvenate
everything and to start to make
everything at least clean but other matt
i gotta make a move here so what i gotta
do is I just got to make just brutal the
noodles and caboodles of maybe maybe
maybe maybe I should keep it contained
here and then just do it through this
and then keep keep the wall separated
and so this way this way I make this way
I don't need to make flooring i can just
dig up to four across all the way up
through here and then for frost all the
way through here so long as they keep it
contained it shouldn't be too much of a
problem and then they sure do love to
dig so I'm just going to assume that
they're going to do this
30 posts taste
the man is so nice just to get a little
bit of algae and then to be able to help
people out like that because it's
amazing how much cleaner it looks
already just from the little bit
the little bit of oxygen production that
was pumped out by that it's the littlest
bit then gone in a flash at least the
terrariums backup from that will be up
for a little bit anyway they're going to
start doing that stuff i'm going to go
ahead and make another like accessible
route to it just to have that there
that's a thing at least ok
look at that it's beautiful you get
algae you get oxygen its suddenly clean
who would have thought food is funked it
huh
food & funk that we would be able to get
oxygen like that also easily
what do you know welcome it's slightly
left hell that it was before now for
either we don't need that
yo cold it's fine you're you look good
I don't need another destructive stress
response or I'll take the pink bubbles
head bobbles come on and i know it sucks
here i know i need to make more beds i
think okay but they're digging that out
please don't unleash that please
there we go okay so they're doing that
thing I don't think they can reach that
that's what that is okay so we're gonna
cancel so they can only go to across for
the the thingamabob ER we're only going
to go to and just go up for now
nice looking good guys looking good look
at this we actually have some oxygen I
can't believe it there any more algae
here there is just a bit tho take that
out right I'm I'm literally getting down
to the last tiny bits of algae and
that's that's just about it that's just
about all I got maybe a small one there
and they're good great this all right
over that one
I mean obviously people are still going
to be stressed for a long time but at
least with clean air hopefully it'll
start to go down and then with clean air
hopefully the temperature will go down
here
yeah it looks like it's already lower
ambient Lee so hopefully these will be
able to be able to go down you know you
could stop reading that anything because
good is actually good
believe it or not this looks better than
it just did
so I think this is a good place to stop
for this episode here because i'm doing
good I'm doing it
this is this legitimately happy new flag
it's starting to get a little intense
the oh no it just grows deposit it is
this good
it's starting to look better these
oxidizers going for repairing what we
can to stress
oddly enough is going down not
everyone's at a hundred percent so we're
doing it
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how i'm doing the comments
below as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye!
*Markiplier's outro music*